doce días después de la polémica visita
de nancy pelosi a taiwán otro grupo de
legisladores estadounidenses llegó sin
previo aviso a las costas de la isla
cinco miembros de una delegación
bipartidista del congreso se reunieron
con la presidenta wen durante el
encuentro se cree que conversaron sobre
comercio seguridad regional y cambio
climático
su visita demuestra que china no puede
impedir que los políticos de cualquier
país visiten taiwán y también envía un
mensaje importante de que eeuu apoya el
pueblo taiwanés
pero beijing lo define como oportunismo
previo a las elecciones de medio término
en estados unidos que se celebrarán en
noviembre y en los que se renueva un
tercio del senado y la totalidad de la
cámara de representantes
el pp quiere manipular la llamada
democracia libertad y derechos humanos
en taiwán por el bien del partido de
parís y mejores veces
affleck
porque eso es solo una bandera para que
el partido movilice el apoyo de la
población local y también obtener algo
de apoyo de washington round washington
dice la visita se produce en medio de
una campaña continua de intimidación
militar de china hacia taiwán beijing
respondió a la visita de nancy pelosi
con una serie de ejercicios militares
sin precedentes alrededor de la isla
cuyo fin había sido anunciado el 10 de
agosto sin embargo el ejército popular
de liberación sigue enviando aviones de
combate y buques de guerra cerca de
taiwán hecho definido por taipei y
washington como un intento de cambiar el
statu quo de taiwán